Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Hallo Freunde Der Weihnachtszeit, hier ist wieder euer Florentin und Stefan, wir haben
für euch wieder eine fantastische Sendung vorbereitet mit vielen Gagspointen und Spielen
und vielleicht, ich bin echt saumülle ohne Scheiße, ich bin gerade einfach aufgewacht.
Also ich verstehe das Problem, dass man morgens müde ist, aber nicht mehr um 15 Uhr nachmittags.
Ich bin aufgewacht, habe mein Mikrofon angesteckt, das ist kein Euphemismus, ich habe mein Mikrofon angesteckt und habe angefangen, dich anzurufen.
Musste dann sogar noch fünf Minuten auf dich warten, um das mal ganz kurz hier anzureissen. Das ist jetzt vielleicht keine Diskussion, die wir vor den Hörern führen müssen, aber ich möchte es mal angesprochen haben. Und jetzt sind wir da. Dann lass uns doch erst mal mit dem ersten Gag loslegen. Nee, weißt du was, ich habe angefangen, mir Kaffee zu machen, jetzt jeden Morgen viel. Und ich habe mir, als du mich angerufen hast, noch kurz meinen Kaffee geholt. Ich habe mir nämlich jetzt eine Kaffeekanne gemacht. Und man merkt jetzt, während der Folge kann man jetzt live, kann der Hörer feststellen, wie ich immer aufgedrehter und unnatürlicher werde. Ja, da freue ich mich schon drauf. Ich habe mir mein Frühstück schon geholt. Ich habe mir gestern Abend in weiser Voraussicht, das mache ich jeden Tag, ich mache mir eine Schüssel voller gefrorener Kirschen, stelle die über die Nacht in den Kühlschrank, damit die am Morgen aufgetaut sind, nämlich die verzehren kann und mische die dann mit einem lustigen Joghurt durch, um das Ganze dann noch ein bisschen... Das ist echt unkürzt. Und jetzt habe ich eine Schüssel Kirschen stehen, aber keinen Löffel oder irgendwas, weil ich nicht damit gerechnet habe. Jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich während der Aufnahme Hunger bekommen und diese ganzen Kirschen einfach wegessen. Und dann Sauer macht lustig. Ich finde es so lustig, dass man, wenn man angerufen wird morgens und geweckt wird dadurch, dass man auf die Frage, habe ich dich geweckt, nicht lügen kann, weil deine Stimme verrät alles über dich. Ich finde es so gut, ich sage immer, nein, nein, aber das ist das Unprofessionellste, was es gibt. Du kannst der beste Schauspieler sein, du musst die Wahrheit sagen, weil die Lüge offensichtlich ist. Das ist so gross. Genau wie, bist du betrunken? Nein. Ja, das war mein erstes Angebot, einer kleinen humoristischen Einleitung in dieses Projekt. Mach mal in meiner Express-Folge, würde ich sagen. Ich wollte dir erstmal... Du willst dich wieder hinlegen, ey. Aber jetzt hör mal auf, wie so ein Tempo reinzubringen. Es ist Weihnachten. Ich bin so in dem Besinnigkeitsmodus gerade. Also bei mir gibt es On, Out und Besinnigkeitsmodus und ich bin gerade mittendrin. Und ich möchte dir nochmal sagen, dass ich es toll finde, was wir hier machen und dass wir es ein Jahr machen. Und ich wollte dich beglückwünschen und zum Einjährigen dir gratulieren.
Ja, vielen Dank. Am 16.
Dezember war es soweit,
unser Einjähriges. Wir haben uns
kurz getroffen, wir haben eine kleine
Sektflasche aufgemacht, wir haben uns kurz noch mal
ein Best-of reingezogen, die besten Momente,
wir haben noch mal mental durchgegangen,
was war damals? Also Folge 12,
Folge 12 war das Best-of,
kann man sagen. Folge 12, ach das war toll,
da haben wir das erste Mal Booster getrunken,
obwohl an viele Dinge kann ich mich ja gar nicht
Vielen Dank. Was war damals? Also Folge 12, Folge 12 war das Best-Off, kann man sagen. Folge 12, ach das war toll, da haben wir das erste Mal Booster getrunken, obwohl an viele Dinge kann ich mich ja gar nicht mehr so genau erinnern und das geht euch genauso wahrscheinlich und deswegen dachten wir uns, wie kann man denn diese ganze Erinnerung so ein bisschen konservieren, wie kann man das so ein bisschen aufheben, wie kann man vielleicht einen Ort schaffen, an dem man gemeinsam in Erinnerung schwelgen kann, wo man sich gemeinsam nochmal eine schöne Zeit machen kann, ein digitales Sektköpfen. Wir haben jetzt ein Tempel der guten Laune, uns errichtet im Internet und das Beste ist, ihr könnt mitbauen. Und deswegen haben wir für jeden von unseren Hörern ein ein Jahres Pornhub-Abo abgeschlossen. Den Code davon könnt ihr euch auf unserer Seite runterladen und damit ein schönes Jahr 2020. Aber lustig, dass sie alle mit XXX beginnen, das finde ich so gut bei Pornhub, dass sie Humor haben und jeder Code ist 69. Ja, das ist ein bisschen humoristisch. Es werden Erwartungen erfüllt. Jeder Code ist XXX 69 sexy, alles groß geschrieben. Ja, genau wie diese Hotlines, sechs mal die sechs, das ist auch ein großer Zufall, dass das so gut passt. Wovon wir natürlich reden, ja, Kinder, ihr merkt schon, ich habe tatsächlich, und ich muss sagen, ich befinde mich auf einem moralischen Tiefpunkt, kennst du das manchmal, dass du, also es gibt ja verschiedene Kategorien der menschlichen Existenz und du bist zum Beispiel gerade müde oder nicht müde, du bist gerade gestresst, ich hasse dich, seitdem du von Hegel klaust. Seitdem du von Hegel klaust. Du kannst Leute aus dem Internet zitieren. Klau meine Gags von Hegel. Du kannst Nein-Gag klauen, aber du hör auf, bitte Gags von Hegel zu klauen. Das gefällt mir nicht. Scheiße, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass du rauskriegst, dass ich meine ganzen guten Porten, dass ich meine ganzen Knaller-Punch-Lights vom guten Gottfried Wilhelm Friedlob-Hege bekomme. Aus Leviathan von Thomas Hobbes. Genau. Und es gibt ja auch eine moralische Kategorie und man fühlt sich manchmal moralisch einfach schlecht. Und ich glaube, ich habe gestern die Erbssünde begangen, die grösstmögliche Sünde habe ich begangen. Und zwar dachte ich mir, und Sünden beginnen ja erst oft mit einem ganz harmlosen Gedanken, mit diesem Gedanken, hm, jetzt ist ja bald Weihnachten, aber ich bin ja zu Weihnachten nicht in Berlin. Mein Adventskalender bleibt aber in Berlin. Das heißt, ich bin zum 24. nicht in derselben Stadt wie mein Adventskalender. Das heißt, ich kann zum 24. nicht den heiligen Akt des letzten Öffnens des Türchens vollziehen. Das heisst, eigentlich könnte ich das ja jetzt schon heute machen. Bitte sag mir nicht, dass du es gemacht hast. Dann dachte ich mir, ne, da ist schon was dran, weil eigentlich ist es besser, das davor zu machen, als dann irgendwie im neuen Jahr. wo dann die, ne, da habe ich den 24. aufgemacht, da dachte ich mir, ja gut, aber ich bin am 23. auch nicht da. Und drin war so ein Zettel, du miese Schwein, es ist noch nicht der 24. Ich bin sehr enttäuscht von dir. Und dann habe ich den 23. auch noch aufgemacht und dann dachte ich mir, ja gut, jetzt kann ich den Rest auch essen. Und jetzt könnt ihr schon den Puffopedia-Eintrag für das große Adventskalender-Massaker vom 19.12. Oh, du leid, ich bin so schwach, ich bin so schwach. Und dann habe ich alle, und dann habe ich wirklich auch, und irgendwann hat es keinen Spaß mehr gemacht, da war es dann wirklich nur noch so ein Vollziehen, einfach, habe ich dann irgendwie die letztlichen fünf oder sechs Türchen aufgerissen und diese Packung bin da gegessen. Das ist, wenn du schon die Technik raus hast, wie du die Türchen am besten aufbekommst. So, dann weißt du, dass es nicht mehr das Genießen ist, sondern nur noch das Essen, die Nahrungsaufnahme. Das ist wie bei Toffifee, wenn man über das Knibbeln hinaus ist und schon diese Technik raushalt, wo man es einfach hinten rausdrückt und einfach sich so die ganze Schachtel innerhalb von zehn Sekunden in den Mund knallt, dann weißt du, wenn du das Öffnen perfektioniert hast, dass es kein Genießen mehr ist, nur noch Fressen. Das ist dann einfach nur noch systematisches Abarbeiten. Es muss dann einfach weg. Und es war echt keine gute Woche für mich. Das war echt, also ein, das war, das war nichts. Ich bin moralisch wirklich auf dem Tiefpunkt. Ich muss mal wieder, ich glaube, ich brauche mal wieder so ein besinnliches Fest irgendwie, wo auch mal die Familie zusammenkommt und man sich nochmal auf seine eigenen Werte besinnt oder sowas. Das wäre jetzt geil irgendwie, das wäre super gut.
Ja, da musst du ein Jahr warten. Nächstes Jahr.
Ja, ja, warten.
Ja gut, aber es ist jetzt die Frage, also wie ist denn das in der Mythologie genau verfasst?
Also da gibt es die schwarze Katze, die Pech bringt, Spiegel bringt Pech.
Die Leiter. Wenn man sich beim Zuprost nicht in die Augen guckt, gibt es Pech, was auch sehr viele Paarlesmüder einfach sehr anstrengend macht, für meine Augen vor allem. Und was ist denn jetzt genau mit dem Adventskalender? Also was ist da jetzt in der Mythologie festgesetzt, was jetzt passiert mit dir? Wirst du jetzt irgendwie von einem Minotaurin ins Nirvana gezogen oder was genau? Ja, man könnte den Gag jetzt in verschiedene Richtungen fortführen. Man könnte jetzt irgendwie so ein kommerzielles Ding draus machen. Weißt du was, mir gefällt das nicht mehr. Seitdem ich dir, also ich werfe dir quasi... Seitdem du mir dieses Buch geschenkt hast, wie ist man lustig? Wie macht man einen guten Podcast? Ich habe dir einen Medizinball-grossen Feedline-Ball zugeworfen. Und seit Folge 13 redest du immer mit mir und sagst, gut, du wirfst mir jetzt gerade einen Ball zu, aber fang ihn doch einfach mal, dann wirf ihn zurück. Ja, okay, hier. Ja, aber, nein, ich habe mich nicht nur gerade in der Unfähigkeit gefunden, diese Feedline zu verarbeiten, deswegen dachte ich mir, ich gehe ins Analytische. Oder bist du so müde noch, dass du gerade nicht in der Lage bist, Medizinballe zu fangen? Der Medizinball, nicht nur ist er nicht zur Hälfte zu mir gekommen, sondern ich habe auch gerade in eine andere Richtung geschaut und habe irgendwie gerade meine Tischtennischläge an der Hand. Das heißt, die Voraussetzungen sind denkbar schlecht dafür, dass du mir jetzt irgendwie gerade was zuwirfst. Erzähl einfach mal ein bisschen, mach mal ein bisschen Programm jetzt. Ja, ich muss sagen, ich erlebe im Moment nicht so viel. Also es wird halt eine total selbstreferenzierte Sendung.
Ich habe mich vorbereitet, dass wir
Einjähriges haben und bin jetzt mit so einer
leichten Feierlaune, die mit jedem Kaffee
stärker zunimmt.
Und ich habe auch überlegt, ich habe meine Gedanken mal schweifen lassen.
Was waren so die Folgen, wo ich
gesagt habe, wow, das ist wirklich
was wir gut gemacht haben, wo sind die
Folge 12 Momente, die furchtbar
waren, wo wir dachten, können wir das überhaupt veröffentlichen. Und letzte Woche war diese tolle Homestory mit Cordula. Ja, das war super. Und alle fanden es so gut. Ich dachte, wir beide waren ja der Meinung, dass wir nicht gut waren in der Folge, nicht gut abgeliefert haben. Und jetzt merkt man mittlerweile, nach einem Jahr haben wir immer noch nicht begriffen, wir wissen immer noch nicht genau, was unsere Hörer eigentlich von uns wollen. Was ich gut finde, es ist so ein Poppourri, so ein Überraschungsei-artiges Leben, was sich gebildet hat. War jetzt wirklich deine Metapher für eine Überraschung ein Überraschungsei? Das war wirklich der mentale kreative Lieb, den du eingegangen bist? Ja. Wow, wie schlecht. Ja, viel Spaß mit den letzten 50 Minuten der Folge, meine Damen und Herren, das wird fantastisch. Ja, nee, das war natürlich super toll. Aber, was auch toll ist, ist ja auch Weihnachtsstress, ne? Mensch, jetzt geht's ja wieder los, die Weihnachtszeit und bla und da. Ab genau jetzt werden wir übrigens unsere, werden wir unentscheidend, jedes Ereignis haben wir schon mal besprochen. Ihr wisst genau, was unsere Einstellung zu Weihnachten ist, was unsere Einstellung zu Geburtstagen ist, Ostern, Pfingsten, die ganzen geilen Feiertage haben wir alle schon mal besprochen. Und jetzt ist es irgendwie, dreht sich das jetzt im Kreis. Also entweder wir müssen es nächstes Jahr als neu erfinden oder lassen es einfach. Ich finde, die größte Spannung an Weihnachten ist für mich, ob die Sachen, die man sich bei Amazon bestellt hat, noch rechtzeitig ankommen. Weil ich habe da auch ein paar so ein bisschen kruden Online-Shops irgendwie so ein paar Sachen bestellt für meine Familie, Geschenke. Ach so, wo Amazon liefert, Amazon oder sind die nur als quasi Distributor aktiv? Nee, über die habe ich nur die Abrechnung gemacht aus irgendeinem Grund, aber der eigentliche Versand läuft über jemand anderen. Und dann habe ich da so ein Produkt bestellt und das ist schon riesengroß Fett, wird nicht mehr zu Weihnachten geliefert. Und ich dachte mir, Zeit für ein Wunder in den Warenkorb. Heiliger Geist, übernimm du, viel Spaß, wir sehen uns an Weihnachten. Wir sehen uns auf der anderen Seite. Natürlich kommt das zu Weihnachten, hallo? Es kann ja nicht sein, dass das dann irgendwie am 26. ankommt. Ich vertraue auf den Geist der Weihnacht und deswegen freue ich mich. Aber tatsächlich, oh Scheiss mal, kurz, also glaubst du, dass man in ein paar Jahren irgendwie den Weihnachtsmann irgendwie mit so einem Amazon-Logo zeigt oder so? Ist nicht quasi, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen, hat sich das verselbstständigt, also der Gedanke von dem Weihnachtsmann, der mittlerweile ja einfach wirklich echt ist, also ... Ja, es gab ja doch schon mal, das fand ich tatsächlich einen sehr guten Move, es gab ja schon, glaube ich, vor zwei oder drei Jahren den Zalando-Mann, dass es dann auch so als Schokoladen-Hohlfigur den Zalando-Mann gab, den man kaufen konnte, fand ich super geil, wo ich mir dachte, endlich eine neue Zeit bricht an, endlich können wir diesen ganzen semi-religiösen Schwachsinn hinter uns lassen und uns dem reinen Kommerz ergeben, endlich hat Kapitalismus alle Facetten des Lebens erreicht, danke, aber jetzt kommen die Junghegelianer, Leute, Weihnachtszeit ist auch mal ein bisschen lesen und stöbern und dann dachte ich mir, endlich haben wir diese neue Stufe des Klassenkampfs erreicht, aber nein, das Proletariat versagt mal wieder und dieses Jahr gibt es das nicht mehr, das finde ich schade tatsächlich. Wo ist das hingekommen? Warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt? Wo man ja auch mal sagen kann, viele verteufeln das ja so, ah, ist ja nur Waren, Fetischismus, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Aber ohne Witz, das ist auch richtig geil. Ey, ich war zu Weihnachten, ich habe jetzt einen Monitor gekauft, weil ich habe mir einen neuen Laptop gekauft mit einem kleineren Bildschirm. Und dann dachte ich mir, ha, kleinerer Bildschirm, hegelische Dialektik ist gleich größerer Bildschirm. Kleinerer Bildschirm, gleich grösserer Spaß. Nein, Moment. Eigentlich, nee, und dann habe ich mir noch einen grösseren Bildschirm gekauft. Das heißt, obwohl ich jetzt einen kleineren Bildschirm habe, habe ich einen grösseren Bildschirm. Und bist du so schau gewesen, dass du den grösseren Bildschirm auf deinen kleinen geklebt hast, dass du quasi, du hast quasi einen kleinen gekauft, aber eigentlich einen grossen. Genau. Schaut mal nochmal in der Begleitlektüre zu der Folge nach, vielleicht versteht ihr dann die Analogie. Naja, auf jeden Fall war ich dann einkaufen und dann siehst du ja die ganzen Eltern mit ihren Kindern, wie sie durch die Wie-Spiel-Abteilung ziehen und die alle mit grossen Augen und du hörst diese Weihnachtsmusik und bist nochmal kurzzeitig in diesem kindlichen Gefühl des, ich habe sehr wenig und alles, was ich habe, liebe ich und wenn ich mehr Dinge bekomme ist das super gut. Und das ist ja schon schön, diese Waren und kaufen und sich begeistern für Dinge. Ich finde das total toll, wenn man das einmal im Jahr machen kann. Und den Rest des Jahres dann kann man ja wieder gütig und hier besinnlich und die ganzen Scheiße. Ich finde das so geil, wie Weihnachten eigentlich noch total konservativ ist, eigentlich auch so, wie man das feiert und dann diese kleinen Figürchen. Und dann war ich gestern zufällig, bin ich auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gelaufen, weil ich mit der Wildnis durch die Stadt gelaufen bin, und dann bin ich plötzlich auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gelandet. Und dann sind da halt diese typischen Jugendlichen. Der 30-jährige Stefan kommt kurz so durch, aber die typischen Jugendlichen mit ihren ... Diese Copy-Paste-Jugendlichen. Mit ihren Bergen, mit ihren Baseball-Caps und ihren ... Mit ihren Lutschern. Mittlerweile diese cool coolen langen Pullis, die aussehen wie Kleider und ihren Kopfhörern. Und dann laufen die da rum und im Hintergrund läuft halt irgendwie Stielenhaar, so ganz klar, aber so richtig klassisch und so ein Mädchenchor singt das dann und ist einfach wahnsinnig kitschig und überall stehen diese kleinen Engelchen und dann sieht man, das passt eigentlich gar nicht mehr in die heutige Zeit ist alles.
Die Jugendlichen warten nur, wann kommt der Drop, wann kommt der Drop, sie sind ja schon ganz nervös, aber da kommt die.
Stille, wop wop wop wop nacht, wop wop wop wop nacht.
Der Dubstep-Remix gibt's hundertprozentig schon, spielen wir jetzt ein.
Nein, tu mir nicht.
Fröhliche wop wop wop wop wop.
Ja, na gut. Entschuldigung. Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,, das war deine Idee. Ja, weil ich mit dem Sonntag noch was anfangen will. Guck mal, draußen ist schönes Wetter. ich kann nicht den ganzen Tag verschlafen und dann gehe ich abends raus und es ist wieder dunkel. Das kann ich nicht machen wie die letzten drei Wochen. Aber nochmal zurück zum Thema Amazon. Ich finde ja, ich schreibe ja gerade ein Buch, moderne Legenden, und ich versuche da ein bisschen aufzuarbeiten, wie sich die Mythologie, dieses Bedürfnis des Menschen nach Mythologie, nach grossen Geschichten, nach Mysterien, nach dunklen Gestalten und Mächten übersetzt in die Neuzeit. Weil es gibt ja auch moderne Mythen und moderne Legenden. Und so zum Beispiel Amazon. Und jetzt ist mir zum Beispiel letztens was passiert. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel in vielen Märchen und vielen gerade Fantasy-Geschichten immer so diese Idee, dass irgendein ganz wichtiger Gegenstand so zerbrochen wird und dann sind die einzelnen Splitter ganz überall der Welt verteilt, und die Helden müssen dann die einzelnen Splitter sammeln, um diesen zusammenzufügen. So ein ganz klassisches, archetypisches Modell. Ja, ist angekommen. Bitte fahre fort. Nee, das war schon echt. Und jetzt habe ich letztens mir bei Amazon drei Packungen Toblerone gekauft, weil ich mir dachte, meine Herren, es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich keine Toblerone habe. Und wenn man alle Toblerones der Welt zusammenfügt, dann kommt eine grosse Pyramide aus dem Himmel gefahren, aus geballtem Marzipan. Ja, viele Leute denken, dass es Marzipan ist. Nein, viele Leute denken ja, das sind Nüsse, die da drin sind, oder Karamell, das ist aber nicht. Das sind so Nougat-Genös, aber darum geht es nicht. Aber wir schweifen ab. Auf jeden Fall, die meisten Leute denken, ja, Tuberone ist richtig geil. Letzte Folge ging um Nougat. Woher habt ihr so gesprochen? Ja, halb Stunden. Nur noch Nougat. Kannst du, weißt du grob, was Nougat ist? Nein. Überhaupt nicht, oder? Und es sind so Dinge, auch ich habe gestern Barbecue-Soße gegessen, also wirklich einen Haufenweise Barbecue-Soße, und dann fiel mir ein, eigentlich weißt du gar nicht, was das genau ist, das ist dieses Geräucher, aber es ist auch nicht wirklich Tomate, aber eigentlich ja doch, weil es auch zu rot ist ein bisschen, aber es ist viel brauner, und was ist da eigentlich drin und nichts auf der Welt schmeckt so wie Barbecue? Vor allem, ich glaube, da sind dann so Dinge drin, die wir Deutsche gar nicht kennen, sowas wie Molasse zum Beispiel. Also vielleicht bin ich jetzt komplett auf dem falschen Dampfer, aber zum Beispiel auch für Rum oder so braucht man ja auch so ein Zeug, das man gar nicht kennt. Ich glaube, das ist auch Molasse, wo man einfach nicht weiß, was das ist. Halt doch mal die Klappe, irgendwie ein World of Warcraft Charakter von dir heißt Molasse und du hast gerade irgendwie nach so einem Namen gesucht. Ich denke mir auch bei Dinge aus. Weißt du, ich glaube, dass Toblerone, das sind diese typischen Groger-Stücke, die man jetzt nicht kennt. Ich dachte, du meinst Dime. Eigentlich ist es Dime drin. Toblerone ist nichts anderes als umhüllter Dime. Hast du schon mal ein Dime gegessen, ey? Ja. Hallo? Du hast mich verloren bei Daim. Also, noch mal ganz kurz, ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz den Funny-Fact festhalten, dass man nicht weiß, was Nougat ist, das aber trotzdem gerne konsumiert. Man ist so unneugierig, ne? Man fragt sich überhaupt nichts. Aber was gibt es also die großen fünf Dinge der Dinge, wo man nicht genau weiß, was sie sind? Wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau nicht genau weiß, was sie sind. Ja, komm, reicht, reicht. Das ist unsynchron, unsynchron.
Also wir haben einmal Nougat, Barbecue-Sauce,
finde ich echt ein Riesenproblem.
Ja, Nougat.
Was ist das eigentlich? Ist das sowas wie,
aber ganz kurz, da möchte ich noch Top 3,
dann
Milka, Nozette,
Nozette, Nozette,
Nozette, man weiß es nicht. Aber auch, Noisette, man weiss es nicht.
Also wenn man nicht genau weiss, was es ist und wie es ausgesprochen wird. Was zur Hölle ist das? Ist das was anderes als Nougat? Ist das dasselbe wie Nougat? Was ist das? Was soll da sein? Dritter Punkt, Puffreis. Mir ist klar, was Reis ist und ich habe auch ein grobes Konzept, was Puff bedeutet im meines Sinne. Aber was zur Hölle ist Puffreis? Also sind es wirklich Reiskörner, die dann irgendwie gebacken werden und dann plötzlich so aufgehen? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das stimmt. Top zwei. Salami. Ich meine, es hat einen eigenen Namen. Welches Tier ist das? Aber man weiß nicht, welches Tier das ist. Es kann alles sein. Aber so sieht kein Tier aus. Kein Tier ist so wurmartig wie Salami aufgebaut. Ich weiß es nicht. Top 4. Komisch. Top 1. Snowboard. Hä? Was ist eigentlich ein Snowboard? Nein, ganz kurz. Top 1, Hoverboard. Ich weiß nicht, was in diesem Ding drin ist, aber ihr habt mir geschickt, und da bin ich sehr dankbar darüber, dass ihr mir den Tipp geschrieben habt, dass die Dinger explodieren. Es sind Videos aufgetaucht im Internet, wo, man sollte darüber nicht lachen, und es wird dann schon ein Scherenproblem, glaube ich, wieder werden. Aber ich fand es sehr lustig, da sind Kinder rumgefahren auf diesen Hoverboards und die sind einfach explodiert. Und dann sind halt in diesen Malls so große Feuerbälle los gewesen und Kinder haben schreiend rumgerannt, dann kamen so Mütter angelaufen mit diesen Feuerwerkslöschern, nein, Feuerlöschern und haben das dann ausgemacht, irgendwie wild. Ja, es könnte aber auch der neue Kevin-James-Film gewesen sein. Also man weiß. Ja, war ganz lustig. Aber ich habe jetzt seitdem noch mehr Angst, darum rumzufahren. Und irgendwie gestern waren ein paar Freunde da und ab und zu piept das Ding einfach. Wenn man es anlässt, dann piept das Ding. Also es fängt einfach an und ich habe denen das vorher erzählt, dass es explodieren könnte und es ging einfach bei jedem Mal, wenn es piept, so ein Riesen Schreck durch die Gruppe. Was ist los gewesen? Und dann, das ist echt ganz schön gruselig, weil, naja, es kann jederzeit explodieren, das ist ein bisschen wie Krokodok, nur in, es geht wirklich um dein Leben und nicht um. Im Grunde ist Terrorismus eigentlich wie in Krokodok, du weißt nie, wann es losgeht. Du weißt nie, wann es passiert, aber du provozierst es auch mit deinem Lebensstil. Ja, das stimmt und das, ja, was ist eigentlich die Message von Krokodok? Also Kinder sollen ja was lernen, deswegen sind alle Dinge, die Kinder bekommen, eigentlich mega lame, sollen sie irgendwas lernen. Weniger Spaß sollen mehr lernen. Was lernt man bei Krokodok? Ja, also ich glaube, dass man Risiko eingehen muss und wenn man denkt, es ... Um was zu bekommen, um die Zähne von einem Krokodil einzudrücken, was sowieso fragwürdig ist, was der Ziel der da ist. Ja gut, das ist die Metapher, das ist nämlich ...
Vor allem überall laufen Kinder auf der Welt rum und einem Krokodil einzudrücken, was sowieso fragwürdig ist. Ja gut, das ist die Metapher. Vor allem überall laufen Kinder auf der Welt rum und versuchen, Krokodilen in den Mund zu fassen und niemand weiß genau warum. Aber ich glaube einfach, dass es die Message ist, du sollst Risiko eingehen und wenn du versagst, ist es nicht so schlimm, weil eigentlich ist es nicht wirklich scharf und auch nicht wirklich tut es weh. Und im Grunde ist es Plastik und dein Bruder hat es sowieso kaputt gemacht, der Oberkiefer fehlt. Und mittlerweile weißt du eh, welcher Zahn gedrückt werden muss, damit das Ding nicht runtergeht. Es ist immer derselbe, ja. Oder was ich mir auch gedacht habe, der moralische... Ey, und Scheiße, ganz kurz übernehmen. Es gibt nämlich diese To-Go-Version von Krokodok. Das ist eine kleine Version, die du halt im Auto mitnehmen kannst und so, die ist halt klein für Urlaub und so. Und da ist es immer der gleiche Zahn.
Das habe ich gewesendet, es ist immer der gleiche Zahn.
Das ist uncool zu spielen, was es überhaupt auf der Welt gibt.
Dein behinderter Bruder hat sehr viel Spaß damit, Beffan.
Der kann sich damit die ganze Fahrt lang vergnügen.
Aber ganz kurz auch nochmal zum Thema moralische Hintergrundgedanken.
Was zur Hölle ist die Botschaft der Zahnfee?
Du kriegst Geld dafür, dass du Zähne verlierst. Dass du Körperteile von dir verschenkst. Also verkaufst eigentlich, das ist im Grunde Organhandel. Organhandel, exakt, ja. Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob Zahn jetzt als Organ durchgeht, aber es ist schon in dem Sinne was. Also du verkaufst Teile von dir. Es ist ein Hartorgan. Es ist ein hart Orga. Ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen so die moderne, du kannst deinen Körper verkaufen
Gesellschaft, die ja eigentlich so ein bisschen verruft geraten ist, um da noch ein bisschen so eine Revival zu erleben. Also, du kannst ruhig deinen Körper verkaufen, das ist okay, mach den Schritt. Ja, vor allem, man müsste ja eigentlich als Kind weiterdenken und mal versuchen, so ein paar abgeschnittene Fingernägel unter das Bett, unter das Kopfkissen zu legen, mal so gucken, was geht noch, was kriege ich dafür so, ja, warum kann ich rausholen, so ein paar Haare abschneiden, mal schauen und einfach so versuchen, einfach seine Körperteile zu verticken.
Das ist auch die grossartige Modern Family Story, wo das kleine Mädchen von Mitch und Cam halt einen Zahn verliert und sie aus Versehen hundert Euro reinmachen. Also hundert Euro, weil sie so müde waren und es einfach nicht geklappt hat, weil die ganze Zeit noch wach war, haben sie aus Versehen 100 Euro unter das Kopf vergessen gelegt und sie hat gefragt, wow, warum hat mir die Zahlen viel so viel gegeben und die Mitschuldigen kämen nur, ja, warum hast du dir die Zahlen viel so viel gegeben? Das ist schon sehr lustig. Ja, wir können ab Folge 5 auch einfach Fremdmaterial machen. Genau, das wollte ich gerade auch sagen. Wir machen einfach Gags über andere. Soll ich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu meiner Urlegende gehen, zu der Toblerone? Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo die hinführt, aber mach mal. Also, ich dachte mir, Toblerone ist ja eigentlich richtig geil mit diesem weißen Nougat oder was zur Hölle auch immer das sein soll. Und tatsächlich, was viele Leute ja nicht wissen, es gibt von den meisten guten Dingen noch bessere Variationen. Zum Beispiel Cola. Gibt es dann auch noch Terry Coke, Vanilla Coke, tolle Sachen. Und bei Toblerone… Können wir bitte mal in Top 5 unseren liebsten Cola-Sorten machen? Nee. Aber ich meine jetzt Coca-Cola-Sorten. Ja, können wir gerne machen. Also, Top 5, Coke Light mit Lemon, Nummer 4, Dr. Pepper, Nummer 3, normale Cola, Nummer zwei, Cherry Coke, Nummer eins, Vanillacoke. So, nächstes Thema. Die Geschichte des verlorenen Adventskalners. Nein, also ich habe mir dann, es gibt ja verschiedene Toblerone-Sorten und zum Beispiel gibt es auch Toblerone Fruits Nuts. Fruits Nuts. Es ist nicht nur spaßig, das zu sagen. Fruits Nuts, Fruits Nuts, sondern mehr als nur Nüsse, wir haben auch Früchte, Fruits and Nuts, sondern ist tatsächlich Toplarone mit Rosinen und Nüssen, unglaublicherweise. Ja, aber Moment mal, ich denke, das ist ja wirklich schon Punk, also wenn das möglich ist, aber dann hast du keine Grenzen mehr, du musst ja irgendwo noch Grenzen bewahren, also wenn das möglich ja das Geile an Top-Lerungen. Ja, aber dann kannst du irgendwann auch Nutella mit Kirschen verkaufen. Ja, warum denn nicht? Mit Bananenstücken. Warum denn nicht? Copyright. Weil du Regeln in der Welt brauchst. Copyright. Ich habe Copyright gesagt. Du darfst leider nicht verwenden, ich habe jetzt den Copyright. Sorry, Nutella, doch doch, ich habe Copyright gesagt. Du musst es dreimal sagen, dich einmal im Kreis drehen und dann kurz das Mikro ausmachen. Aber jetzt, ich habe Copyright gesagt, deswegen habe ich fünf Minuten Zeit, das zu machen. Ich habe aber Spiegelhandbewegungen gemacht. Spiegel! Und scheiße, ich bin auch mittlerweile so unschlagfertig. Also, je länger das Jahr wird, umso leerer ist mein Akku. Und auch wenn Leute mich irgendwie anmachen und so Gags in meine Richtung machen, kriege ich nur noch selber und ne, deine Mutter ist blöd raus und so. Es ist wirklich echt, wir brauchen echt Pause. Ohne Witz, aber man rechnet auch einfach nicht damit, dass Leute Schlagfähigkeit erwarten. Ich habe ja gestern diesen Monitor gekauft, habe nur diesen riesigen Monitor genommen und habe ihn zur Kasse geschleppt. Und da stand so ein Security-Typ und ich hatte gerade Kopfhörer drin und habe Podcast gehört und hat der Security-Typ zum Beispiel gesagt, ja, es wäre doch nicht nötig gewesen. Und dann, tue ich die Kopfhörer raus wie bei dir? Ja, es wäre doch nicht nötig gewesen. Leute dazu zu bringen, den Gag noch mal zu wiederholen. Du gewiefter Hund! Vor allem, ich dachte, meine erste instinktive Reaktion war, ich hätte ihn nicht zur Kasse tragen müssen, weil ein Mitarbeiter hätte ihn mir zur Kasse getragen, dachte ich. Es ist gut, dass du automatisch von schlechten Versionen eines Gags ausgehst. Nee, ich dachte nicht mal, dass es ein Gag wäre, sondern einfach so, ja, wir haben auch den Service, dass wir die Waren zur Kasse tragen. Und dann ich so, ja, wie bitte? Na, dass du zumindest hier als Geschenk bringst. Ach so. Ciao, ciao. Und dann einfach habe ich wirklich kurz gelächelt, aber wirklich innerhalb von vier Millisekunden wieder zurück in den Mundwinkel runter und in den Ernstblick zurück und dann standen wir erst mal daneben, bis die Kasse frei war. Alter, war der unangenehm. Also den Gag macht er wahrscheinlich bei jeder einzelnen Person den ganzen Tag, egal was da kommt. Das war nicht nötig gewesen. Wie bitte? Das war nicht nötig gewesen, dass sie mir das schenken. Cool wäre, wenn jeder hinter dir und dir davor dir eine geile Antwort drauf gehabt hätte und irgendwie so die großen Gagbelts beginnen und dann kommt Florentin Will Comedy Mastermind an und versagt einfach bei so einer kleinen Punchline. Genau. Aber Toblerone ist ja für mich so das Traditionellste, was es überhaupt gibt. So Berge, ne Ural... Mir gefällt das nicht, wie lange wir jetzt schon über Toblerone reden. Ja, ja. Also es wird nicht, es nimmt, also seitdem... Mein Gott, ja, dann fasse ich es mal einfach zusammen. Ich habe drei fucking Varianten von Toblerone bestellt. Und das Interessante und das Lustige und warum ich die Gattekdote überhaupt erzähle, ist, dass alle drei Tobleronesorten irgendwo anders hingeschickt wurden. Die erste Toblerone kam zu mir, Akt 1, boring. Gegessen war sehr gut. 400 Gramm, motherfucker, 400 Gramm, ja, das sind 2400 Kalorien, die ich einfach so an einem Tag gegessen habe, normal, ja, kein Problem. Aber du hast heute Kirchen zum Frühstück gegessen, das heißt, du hast es ungefähr plus minus, weil wenn man Obst isst, nimmt man ab. Perfekt. Und die zweite Packung ging zu einer Packstation, wo ich sie dann abholen wollte. Und da war wirklich, also das klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber diese Packstation war dahingehend sehr interessant, weil alle Leute, die da gearbeitet haben, waren gehbehindert. Waren Wichtel, so Weihnachtsmann Wichtel. So ein bisschen den Eindruck hatte er es auf mich gemacht, weil jeder in dem Laden war gehbehindert. Und da ist mir auch so, was ist denn jetzt los? Und vor allem, also die Situation war auch wieder mega scheiße, weil ich war irgendwie sieben Tage zu spät und dann hieß es, ja, das Paket ist wahrscheinlich schon zurückgeschickt und dann haben sie dieses Paket überall gesucht und nirgendwo das Paket gefunden und dann, ja, ich ruf mal den Typen an, dann kam der Geschäftsführer, hat angerufen, dann haben sie bei anderen Parkstationen angerufen, ob da das Paket ist, also ein riesen Aufwand gemacht. Für Toblerone, wo Leute auch gesagt haben, was ist denn da drin, irgendwie Geld, ne, Toblerone. Ja, Geld, natürlich, man versendet Geld, man versendet Geldscheine einfach so durch die Gegend, ganz klassisch. Und dann, weißt du, suchen die irgendwie 25 Minuten und dann irgendwann, ach hier ist es ja, lag die ganze Zeit einfach direkt vor ihm auf dem Tisch. Ach hier ist es ja. So angegessen auch. Und dann tatsächlich war dann auch so die Situation, wo ich mir dachte, okay, ich habe jetzt mit drei Menschen hier interagiert, die waren alle 3G behindert, das ist wirklich auffällig, was ist hier los? Und dann ruft einer zum Typen, der ganz hinten sitzt im Raum so, Herbert, kannst du mal kommen? Und ich dachte mir, das kann nicht wahr sein. Und er steht auf, dreht sich und auch der klassische Fuss hinter sich herziehen. Wo ich dachte, was ist denn hier los? Warum sind denn hier alle Gebehindert? Das ist auch so eine Situation, wenn man einen behinderten Typen auf der Straße sieht, kein Problem. Aber wenn man irgendwo rumkommt, wo alle komischerweise behindert sind, ist es einfach seltsam. Wie hast du reagiert, dass du ein bisschen scheinbar... Ich musste laut lachen, weil es auch so dramaturgisch perfekt war, dieser ewig lange Gang, der perspektivisch so mit flackernden Lichtern irgendwie hinten nach hinten ging. Und dann von ganz hinten kommt dieser Typ und kratzt sich so langsam seinen Weg nach vorne. Aber so ist es wahrscheinlich, weil das ist ja ein knallharter Job, diese ganzen Pakete, man merkt ja nicht, was man da alles überhaupt für Menschen. Ja, der Weihnachtsmann hat ja auch diese Wichtel und die sind wahrscheinlich auch alle ein bisschen behindert. Ja, die sind halt klein so ein bisschen. Zweigwüchsig. Ja, und das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein knallharter Job, so diese Pakete den ganzen Tag durch die Gegend zu fahren. Und wenn man dann dadurch halt behindert wird, ich glaube, so funktionieren Behinderungen, wenn man dadurch halt irgendwann behindert wird, dann arbeitet man hinter der Packstation. Das war genau wie früher, die Leute, die keine Beine hatten, haben halt dann einen Bogen gebaut. So ist das nun mal. Also wir haben nämlich, da wo ich herkomme, das ist meine Heimat, da war in der, es war ein Stadtteil, und der Stadtteil war eigentlich nur bekannt für seine Behindertenwerkstatt. Wow, das muss der krasseste Stadtteil aller Zeiten sein. Das ist das beste, was es zu liefern. Und als Kind geht man damit ja sehr unbefangen um.
Und ich dachte auch seit meines Lebens, dass es erst eine normale Werkstatt wurde, da irgendein Unglück passiert ist, worauf es eine Behindertenwerkstatt wurde. Und dann kam, es war wirklich eigentlich relativ verstörend. Also dann kam immer jeden Morgen der Bus, der die dann gebracht hat, weil die auch nicht alleine zur Arbeit kommen können. Und dann auf meinem Schulweg bin ich jeden Morgen, kam dann dieser Bus vorbei mit diesen beschlagenen Scheiben, wo Menschen einfach dann wahnsinnig irre draus gewunken haben. Das war so irgendwie so ein Horrorfilm-Szenario. Also es war wirklich ein Friedhof, dann eine Strasse und dann die Behindertenwerkstatt. Und jeden Morgen laufe ich da am Friedhof lang und dann kommt plötzlich dieser Bus mit den beschlagenen Scheiben und überall klatscht so eine Hand ans Fenster und wirft dann so die Scheibe runtergezogen und dann presst sich plötzlich so ein Gesicht mit so wahnsinnig einem grossen Auge.
Ja, hier ist schon klar, dass wir gerade behinderte Menschen mit Horrorfilmprotagonisten vergleichen.
Mit Zombies.
Mit Zombies im Grunde.
Also nur um ganz kurz festzuhalten, wo wir gerade sind. Aber ich tatsächlich, ich war auch in so einem Inklusionskindergarten, also entweder das oder ich war auch behindert als Kind, wo auch behinderte Kinder waren und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr, wie ich das damals verarbeitet habe, wo ich mir einfach dachte, ja gut, die sind halt ein bisschen komisch, die sind halt ein bisschen strange und manche sitzen den ganzen Tag in einem Stuhl rum mit Rollen dran, was eigentlich eine geile Idee ist, warum habe ich nicht so einen Stuhl, aber ich kann mich nicht mehr hundertprozentig erinnern, wie ich das als Kind verarbeitet habe, wahrscheinlich nimmt man das einfach so, ja, die sind halt komisch, aber warum nicht?
Vor allem, man denkt ja auch mal, dass man so normal war als Kind, aber ich habe dann irgendwann mal eine Kindergärtnerin getroffen, also sie hat mich noch erkannt, ich sie nicht, und dann hat sie mir, dann dachte ich immer, ich wäre ein normales Kind, ein aufgeschlossenes Kind im Kindergarten gewesen, und dann hat sie mir Dinge erzählt, die ich einfach nicht glauben konnte. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich habe echt die meiste Zeit geschlafen im Kindergarten. Sie hat mir gesagt, es gab eine Kuschelecke, habe ich dir mal vielleicht erzählt, glaube ich hier. Aber es gab immer eine Kuschelecke, und die war immer gesperrt, weil ich darin gepennt habe. Und zwar wirklich die ersten drei Jahre habe ich im Kindergarten nur geschlafen, hat sie gesagt. Und die haben sich schon einfach angefangen, Sorgen zu machen, weil ich so viel geschlafen habe. Und andauernd war diese Ecke halt
besetzt und alle wollten da rein und dann hieß es, nee, Stefan schläft da. Das war einfach ein Satz, der
einfach akzeptiert wurde. Stefan ist in. Das war wirklich ein Satz, der akzeptiert wurde als, okay, ich kann
ja jetzt nicht reingehen, Stefan ist da drin. Das ist aber nicht die dümmste Idee, seine Kindergartenzeit zu
verbringen, ne? Einfach zu sagen, du machst ja eh nichts Produktives, also schlaf einfach. Ja, also ich bin echt immer stets aus dem Bett gekommen und ich habe irgendwann wahrscheinlich einfach gesagt, ja komm, bring mich jetzt ins Kindergarten, penne ich halt da weiter, ist mir egal. Komm Mama, bring mich einfach da hin, ist mir egal, passt schon. Ich schlappe sich in der Aktentasche und seinen Hut und ging in den Kindergarten. Aber warum warst du so müde? Hast du die ganze Nacht im Kohlebergwerk gearbeitet oder was?
Oder was war da los?
Ich hab die ganze Nacht durchgefögelt.
Ich war einfach ein sehr aktives Kind.
Ja, alles klar.
Du hattest mit acht Jahren schon den ganzen Sex für dein Leben und dachtest dir, gut, abgeschlossen, ab jetzt nur noch Swagways.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ich habe viel SpongeBob geguckt.
Viel SpongeBob-Marathon.
In deiner Kindheit gab es schon SpongeBob? SpongeBob. Sponge. Sponge. SpongeBob. Eigentlich auch eine geile Komödieserie für Kinder. Ja. Glaubst du, dass es uns geprägt hat? Wie eine Komödieserie da draußen. Glaubst du, dass es der Humor ist, der uns geprägt hat? SpongeBob? Ja, kann sein. Also bei mir, glaube ich, eher Simpsons, weil Simpsons gab es von früher an. Aber Simpsons versteht man glaube ich als Kind die Humorebene nicht so doll wie bei, weil die halt eher, also die Humorebene ist glaube ich eher für Erwachsene und diese Freundschaftengeschichten und so, das ist eher für Kinder. Ja, ich glaube, dass die Kinder da nicht so viel Humor ausstehen, weiss ich nicht. Das sind diese vagen Thesen, wo ich nicht mal ein Beispiel für habe, da um was zu untermauern, wo ich mir vorher nicht mehr Gedanken gemacht habe, jemals in meinem Leben, wo ich einfach den Gedanken im Podcast entwickle und es einfach raushaue, als wäre es Wissen. Uncool. Wie sieht es aus, hast du schon Geschenke? Ja, klassisch auch Amazon, also dieses Jahr alles bei Amazon bestellt. Ist es nicht das beste Gefühl, wenn du weißt, was du schenken kannst, es bei Amazon eingibst und es gibt es einfach da? Deswegen wiederhole ich einfach den Satz, den ich jedes Jahr wiederhole, das schönste Geschenk, was man Leuten machen kann, ist sich Dinge wünschen. Das Beste, was man jemandem abnehmen kann, ist der Weihnachtsstress, da sagst du ihm einfach, ich hätte gerne hier diesen blinkenden, leuchten Dildo. Weißt du, was wir jetzt machen? Wir sagen jetzt mal, angenommen, uns will irgendwer aus der Community was schenken, um es euch leichter zu machen. Also, folgendes habe ich euch aufgestellt. Ich hätte gerne einen 25-Euro-Gutschein bei Chibo wünschen wir dieses Jahr. Okay, ich hätte gerne irgendwas mit Magneten. Also, ich habe schon diese Nano-Dots, da hab ich jetzt 125 von.
Hätte ich gerne irgendwann mal im Laufenden meines Lebens,
hätte ich da gerne 1.000, das sind nur Marken, die ich gerne erreichen würde.
Also, hätte ich da gerne noch mal von euch in ein Erweiterungspack.
Ich wünsche mir noch einen 25-Euro-Gutschein für Chibo.
Ich wünsche mir gerne das Master-Replikas Luke Skywalker Schwert FX. Ich wünsche mir 60 Twitter-Follower. Warum? Hast du dann eine Marke erreicht? Nein, weil ich einfach mehr Twitter-Follower haben möchte. Aber eigentlich, der Gutschein ist schon wirklich ein sehr seltsames Konzept an sich, weil es ist eigentlich wie Gailt, nur nicht so flexibel. Nee, genau, vor allem ist es einschränkend.
Es ist auch so ein bisschen so, ich will, dass du dir was kaufen kannst, aber nur von der Meierischen Buchanlung.
Du schenkst im Grunde Einschränkung.
Das ist natürlich auch ein gewisser, weil ein Geschenk ist immer eine Einschränkung.
Und ein Geschenk ist immer eine Beleidigung.
Du hast ja die materielle Welt mit allen Gegenständen und suchst dir davon eine aus,
weil jedes Geschenk heißt ja auch immer, ich schenke dir jetzt x, aber ich schenke dir minus x nicht. Du musst es ja auch mal ein bisschen dialektisch betrachten. Das ist ja auch viel negativer. Danke Mama und Papa, dass ich mir ein Fernseher geschenkt habe, aber ihr habt mir kein Auto geschenkt. Wo ist mein Snowboard? Ja, genau. Im Grunde schliessst du damit ein bisschen. Ich habe schon zwei Mal das Wort Snowboard erwähnt heute. Ja, ich habe so eine kleine Challenge mir gestellt. Da will aber jemand Snowboards doch Weihnachten. Ja, ja. Ich habe mir so eine kleine Challenge gestellt, damit es dir so langweilig wird. Ich muss gewisse Worte unterbringen im Podcast. Und je häufiger ich sie unterbringen kann, Chibo habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Deswegen habe ich schon mehr Punkte als du. Und ja, im Grunde ist es tatsächlich sehr, sehr seltsam. Deswegen dachte ich mir, mal über Gutscheine reden. Ich war kurz davor zu sagen, Top 5 der unbrauchbarsten Gutscheine, aber da dachte ich mir, ob ich das deliveren kann. Man muss aber differenzieren, von wem die Gutscheine kommen. Also ich habe mir, ab und zu bestelle ich mir halt Dinge und dann sind da drin Gutscheine von befreundeten Unternehmen, irgendwie auch von diesem HelloFresh, von dem ich mal erzählt habe.
Und wenn du Gutscheine findest, im Karton zum Beispiel, ist es immer etwas, wo ich jetzt gelernt habe in diesem Jahr auch, dass man wirklich vorsichtig sein muss, weil man immer ... Ich bin bestimmt in diesem Jahr fünfmal in so Vertrags-Abo-Dingen gefangen gewesen einfach. Wehe, Kauf, Stefan! Und das ist jetzt mittlerweile mittlerweile glaube ich, bin ich da weiter, aber in diesem Jahr bin ich mehrmals in diese Falle getappt. Und also, wenn Gutscheine von Leuten kommen, die ihr kennt, nehmt es ruhig an, sagt Danke und besorgt euch was davon, wenn die Gutscheine, wenn ihr die findet, im Karton oder so, vorsichtig sein. Das war mein Tipp der Woche.
Auch so Gutscheine irgendwie so fünfmal Zimmer aufräumen oder sowas.
Oder fünfmal... Weißt du noch, letztes Jahr, da habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich meinem Vater die Maus geschenkt habe, die er schon hatte.
Ich habe ihm das Geld dafür noch nicht gegeben, ohne Scheiß.
Also ich habe einfach nur...
Das habe ich das ganze Jahr vergessen. Ich habe genau ein Jahr alles vergessen. Ich denke, ich schenke ihm dieses Jahr nochmal. Nochmal dieselbe Maus, das wäre eigentlich ganz geil. Das wäre ein guter Gag. Oder ich verpacke einfach random Dinge in der Wohnung. Das ist tatsächlich auch so, man muss sich manchmal einfach den Gag trauen. Meine Oma hatte im Dezember Geburtstag und da habe ich eine Karte geschrieben. da dachte ich mir, wie fucking lustig wäre es denn, die Karte so, hallo Oma, alles Gute zum Geburtstag, feier schön, ha ha ha ha und da einfach nochmal so einen schönen Zehner reinlegen, hat nochmal seine eigene Oma eine Grußkarte mit einem Zehner schenken. Oder die ganze Zeit mit dem nahenden Tod rumgecken. Genau, ja, vielleicht ist es der letzte Weihnachten und ich wünsche viel Spaß damit.
Hau nochmal auf die Kacke, bitteschön, Zehner. Fünfer. Ich finde, ein Fünfer ist eine wahnsinnige Beleidigung eigentlich auch. Ja, deswegen finde ich ein Zehner lustiger fast, weil ein Fünfer ist schon wieder fast beleidigend, weil es der kleinste mögliche Schein ist. Aber ein Zehner ist so, es ist wenig, aber es könnte schon ernst gemeint sein. Aber einfach, wie würde man als Oma reagieren? Als kriegst du einen Zehner. Was machst du denn damit? Also das ist schon beim einfach mal so umdrehen, so die Machtbehältnisse. PS, sag Opa davon nichts. Ja genau, ja, kauf dir was Schönes. Also du hast ja mal die Regel aufgestellt letztes Jahr, was ich sehr gut fand, dass man Leuten nur das schenken soll, was sie schon haben, weil das sind ja Dinge, die sie brauchen und wollen. Da habe ich massive Kritik geerntet übrigens, ich erinnere mich daran, dass deswegen jemand gesagt hat, ich hoffe, dass du mir niemals etwas schenkst, was so glaube ich das mitbeleidigendste der Welt ist, ich hoffe, dass du mir niemals was schenkst, was Schenken das Schönste ist, was man jemandem antun kann, aber deswegen, ich finde es gut, dass du dich an die Regeln erinnerst, aber sie mit Vorsicht genießen, sage ich mal. Und vor allem auch Dinge schenken, die kaputt gegangen sind in der letzten Zeit. Das ist halt mega gut.
Ja, die man selbst kaputt gemacht hat bei der Person vielleicht. Genau, und jetzt würde ich gerne einen Schritt weiter gehen, dass an Vorweihnachten, wenn man gar nicht weiß, was man schenken soll, kann man Dinge des anderen kaputt machen, um dann quasi aktiv das Ding nochmal neu zu kaufen. Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich genau das gemacht, was wir eigentlich gesagt haben, das wir nicht machen. Und ich habe extra das nochmal wiederholt danach, um schneiden zu können. Ach, scheiße. Nee, wir schneiden heute mal nicht. Kannst du mal lachen kurz, damit ich das da nahranschneiden kann? Ja, aber du hast schon recht. Worüber wir noch sprechen wollten, eigentlich, oder ich weiß nicht, ob du darüber sprechen willst, weil es liegt ja auf dem Herzen und ich merke, das kommt schon so ein bisschen durch irgendwie bei dir, so zwischen Zeilen. Jetzt komm, sag's doch, was mit Star Wars jetzt? Also ich war jetzt, ich war gestern nochmal im Kino. Ich war auch gestern nochmal im Kino tatsächlich. Echt jetzt? Ich habe ihn jetzt zweimal gesehen, ja. Ich habe ihn einmal in Deutsch gesehen, einmal auf Englisch jetzt, weil ich es nicht ertragen habe, aber ich habe halt zur primären Zeit kein englisches Kino gefunden hier in Köln, was echt ein Problem ist. Du hast den X-Flügler gesehen, den X-Flügler hast du da gesehen. Genau, den X-Flügler und die erste Order. Naja, gut. Original hieß er X-Wing, also das X-Deutsch gesprochen, aber Wing Englisch, Ex-Wing. Ja, also ich finde es echt ein ... Also ich habe aber beim ersten Mal gucken, hatte ich noch meine Probleme mit manchen Sachen. Ich fand das ein grandioses Film beim ersten Mal gucken schon, aber hatte noch ein paar Probleme damit. Ich fand zum Beispiel, das erste dachte ich, es wären zu viele Gags. Der Film hat sich zu unernst genommen, das war bei den anderen so cool, die konnte man geil parodieren, weil sie sich zu ernst genommen haben. Das war so ein bisschen der Flair und die waren so lustig, weil sie es so ernst genommen haben und weil Han Solo so ein riesiges Arschloch eigentlich ist und so.
Das fand ich beim diesem Mal, hat mich erst ein bisschen gestört, aber im Endeffekt habe ich das nochmal gesehen und ich fand beim zweiten Mal gucken noch wesentlich besser. Ich fand ihn wirklich unbeschreiblich gut. Also ich bin ein Riesenffan von Star Wars und aber das fand ich
wirklich trotzdem,
obwohl man halt aus dieser Fansicht
sich eigentlich immer mehr einschränkt, was eigentlich
paradox ist, aber du hast halt so viel Erwartung
an ein Produkt am Ende, was
es eigentlich schwer erfüllen kann nur noch, aber das muss ich sagen,
war echt was, was wirklich gut
gewesen, wirklich gut gemacht war.
Aber angenommen, man möchte jetzt eine ausführlichere Meinung
von dir zu dem Thema hören.
Ja, dann kann man anderen Podcasts hören, aber der ist noch nicht bereit dafür, massiv beworben zu werden, oder? Also meine ich jetzt ganz... Ich finde schon und ich weiß nicht, warum ich dich da so zu bringen muss, weil ich finde, das ist ein fantastischer Podcast. Aber das hast du beim ersten Mal nicht gesagt, als ich gefragt habe, wie du den findest. Dass du so gesagt hast, ja... Weil ich Weil dich ein bisschen motivieren will. Oh, hast du gesagt. Naja, ich musste mich durchbeissen. Ja, dann könnt ihr gerne meinen neuen Podcast hören, den ich mit einem Kollegen mache, der auch ein enormer Star Wars Fan ist. Zusammen machen wir den Podcast Antenne Alderaan und hört doch gerne mal rein, da werden wir auch über einen neuen Film sprechen. Aber auf der anderen Seite braucht es auch keine zwei Dödel, die jetzt noch mal den Film rezensieren.
Nein, das ist das Letzte, was es braucht.
Genau, deswegen so ein bisschen einfach mal die neuen Charaktere erklären,
gucken, alles ein bisschen einzuordnen im Gesamtkontext,
so ein bisschen nerdig daran zu gehen.
Apropos ...
Wie hat es dir denn gefallen?
Ähm, also, ich hatte sehr grosse Bedenken,
dass sich im Kino neben irgendeinem Vollidioten sitzt,
der die ganze Zeit redet.
Und das hab ich ... Ich auch, und du hast es ein bisschen, du hast irgendwann mal, jetzt habe ich alles rausgeschnitten, aber du hast bei der Donny Sullivan Folge wahnsinnig darüber hergezogen, über Leute, die im Kino reden. Und seitdem achte ich auch massiv darauf, weil es mich auch nervt, aber seitdem du das angesprochen hast, nervst mich noch massiver. Und man ist aber die ganze Zeit, wenn man dieses Bewusstsein entwickelt, nur damit beschäftigt, schlechte Dinge im Kino zu suchen und Leute zu suchen, die einen aufregen könnten. Ja, das ist mein Leben. Ich suche immer nach Dingen, die mich unglücklich machen könnten. Genau, und du bist also quasi schon unglücklich, bevor etwas passiert, weil es passieren könnte. Und das macht einen wahnsinnig. Und deswegen kann man es im Kino eigentlich nicht wirklich genießen. Und tatsächlich, weil ich glaube, echte Fans würden im Kino nicht reden, weil sie Respekt haben vor dem Film, weil sie Respekt haben vor den anderen Fans, die so lange darauf gewartet haben.
Und dann gibt es aber noch diesen widerlichen Mittelteil der beschissenen Arschloch-Fans, die dann irgendwie wieder prahlen wollen und ihre tollen Theorien darstellen wollen und Ah, hab ich dir doch gesagt, ich hab dir doch gesagt, dass die Uda jetzt böse ist, ne ne ne ne ne und so einen Schwachsinn. Ja, und dann war ich im Kino und habe mich hingesetzt und direkt rechts vor mir waren so drei Vollspasten, die du einfach schon direkt vom Gesicht ablesen könntest, Vollidiot, ja, und die schon die ganze Zeit davor Gags gemacht haben und und natürlich, es kam, wie es kommen musste, haben wir natürlich den ganzen Film darüber geredet. Echt jetzt? Und weißt du, da freust du dich einfach eineinhalb Jahre lang auf den Film. Haben die jetzt echt auf? Und dann reden die, aber es war mir komplett egal. Sau, ach guck mal, wow, Florentin entwickelt sich. Es war mir tatsächlich komplett egal, was glaube ich eines der grossmöglichen Lobe ist, die man in diesem Film aussprechen kann. Ich war so tief drin und war so gefesselt, dass es mir scheißegal war. Ich habe das schon bemerkt,
aber nicht wie sonst,
dass ich mir gar nicht, ich weiß, der war mir nicht,
sondern ich dachte mir einfach, ja, ist mir scheißegal.
Das zweite Mal, als ich gesehen habe,
also ich habe beidisch Englisch
gesehen, das zweite Mal war eine Mutter
mit ihren kleinen Töchtern vor mir
und ich dachte mir, oh, das ist schon okay,
also entweder sind die bilingual aufgewachsen oder
sie sind sehr talentiert, dass sie einen Film in Englisch anschauen können. Ne, konnten kein Englisch. Oh nein! Und was dazu geführt hat, dass sie den Film einfach von vorne bis hinten nicht verstanden haben. Und die Mutter die ganze Zeit simultan übersetzt hat. Und dann gefragt haben, was hat er gerade gesagt, wo ich mir echt dachte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Du kannst doch mit deinen Kindern, die kein Englisch sprechen, nicht in englischen Filmen gehen. Es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es in Berlin keine Kinos, die den Filmen auf Deutsch zeigen. Das ist genau so, wenn man Vegetarier zum Steakhaus mitnehmen oder so. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob der Mutter das bewusst war oder ob sie einfach zehn Minuten nach Beginn des Films dachte, oh scheiße. Zehn Minuten, weil das erste Wort gesprochen wird. Ja, gut, aber wie hast du es empfunden trotzdem? Also ich würde jetzt inhaltlich mal mit dir reden. Also auch da, sag ich mal, war es sehr nervig, aber ich bin noch nicht hundert Prozent in der Lage, mir eine Meinung zu bilden. Es gibt schon ein paar Kritikpunkte, aber die eher auf einer Meta-Ebene funktionieren. Also an sich ist es ein sehr unterhaltsamer Film, supergut, er hat wahnsinnig viel richtig gemacht, aber er hat vielleicht fast sogar schon zu viel richtig gemacht, es war wahnsinnig viel Fanservice, ich finde, J.J. Abrams hat sich an vielen Stellen zu leicht gemacht und hat einfach viele, es fühlte sich so ein bisschen an wie ein Remake, die Elemente waren wirklich fast gleich. Es war ein Remix des vierten Teils, kann man sagen, also so ein moderner Remix. Und der Film funktioniert, finde ich, überhaupt nicht alleinstehend. Also das war einfach so ein riesen Exposition-Film. Der Setting ist jetzt klar für die nächsten Filme. Man weiss, die Personenkonstellation ist jetzt mega gut exponiert und man weiss genau, was jetzt passiert, im nächsten Teil und wie der anfängt. Das ist alles geil, aber er funktioniert nicht als einzelner Teil. Aber das hat mich beim ersten Mal auch wahnsinnig gestört, habe mich auch genauso gesehen wie du, aber beim Zeitpunkt mal gucken schon gar nicht mehr. Es sind natürlich megaviele Moves drin, die wahnsinnig clever sind, auch dass man diese alten Legenden um Luke Skywalker und Han Solo als die grosse Legende darstellt, wo dann auch sozusagen die Hauptdarsteller so Fans der Urtrilogie sind, genauso wie man selbst Fan der Urtrilogie ist. Und wenn jemand sagt Luke Skywalker, dann alle, was Luke Skywalker und man selber genau das gleiche Gefühl hat. Das ist natürlich sehr einfach. Und vor allem der erste Satz des Films war ja, wie dann Max von Bilo, wie weiß ich, wie man ihn ausspricht, der steht am Anfang in diesem Zelt, der alte Mann, und sagt dann, ab jetzt fangen wir an, Dinge richtig zu machen. Das ist der erste Satz des Films, wo man sich auch darüber nachdenken kann, wie ist das gemeint, wie ist es in der Metaebene auch zu verstehen. Also ganz interessant eigentlich. Nee, absolut, und da sind die Sequels von der Aufgabe natürlich wesentlich einfacher als die Prequels, weil der Prequels kannst du überhaupt nichts abgreifen von diesem alten Star-Wars-Hype, ausser mal irgendwie Yoda zu zeigen oder so, der dann cool wird. Aber da war es natürlich sehr einfach, weil man sich einfach narrativ auf einer ähnlichen Ebene befindet und deswegen hat es sehr gut funktioniert. Aber ich finde, man kann natürlich, klar, J.J. Abrams, wenn überhaupt, vorwerfen, dass er sich nicht zu viel getraut hat und zu wenig seine eigene Geschichte erzählt hat, als einfach die alte Geschichte. Nochmal, man muss dann natürlich aber sagen, er hat natürlich eine wahnsinnig große Verantwortung. Und da kann man auch verstehen, dass er mal ein bisschen auf Sicherheit spielt, und deswegen war es auch nicht schlimm. Vor allem fandst du einen, ich fand da vor allem keinen Film richtig geil von ihm. Und ich bin auch nicht so traurig darüber. Star Trek war aber schon ganz geil. Also ich bin froh darüber, dass er vielleicht nicht ganz seine Geschichte erzählt hat, sondern einfach dieser Fanservice natürlich auch, auf der einen Seite hat mich am Anfang auch ein bisschen genervt, aber eigentlich... Aber es ist halt, er wird halt kein Klassiker werden, weil er sich zu sehr an andere dranhängt. Er hat halt keine eigenen Catchphrases, er hat keine eigenen coolen Momente, sondern er kopiert halt nur die ganzen coolen Momente aus den anderen Filmen. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Nein, nein, nein. Also am Anfang zum Beispiel dieses Festhalten, dieses Laserkanone, die einfach dann die Luft anhalten. Das sind ja Variationen von Dingen, die es schon gab irgendwo so. Und da kann man natürlich viel spielen. Aber jetzt so von Narrativen, Beats und dramaturgischen Plotpunkten war da einfach viel übernommen, was aber auch okay ist. Und einfach fucking Kylo Ren ist der fucking coolste Bösewicht aller Zeiten.
Fucking badass, mega cool, finde ich auch mal richtig geil, einen Bösewicht zu haben, der einfach noch nicht fertig ist, der irgendwie unfertig ist, der selber hadert und selber noch auf einem Weg ist, was es wirklich sehr selten gibt. Also klar, gerade Episode vier, Darth Vader, der böse Maskenmann, da fand ich einmal die Idee zu haben, einen schwächelnden Bösewicht, der selber in der ersten Teil einer Trilogie ja selber noch lernt und selber noch krasser und böser wird. Ja, und vor allem, der so böse ist, dass er den kleinsten hellen Teil, den er in sich spürt, einfach loswerden will. Also das macht ihn dann noch böser als Darth Vader. Und da habe ich ja tatsächlich eine, sag ich mal, wir wollen ja nicht spoilern, einen wichtigen Dialog mit einer anderen wichtigen Person gegen Ende des Films, habe ich tatsächlich erst beim zweiten Mal sehen, wirklich verstanden, wie dieser Dialog gemeint ist. Und das ist tatsächlich auch dramaturgisch ein sehr cooler Kniff und da muss ich sagen, geil, geiles Ding. Okay, ja, viel Spaß mit Star Wars.
Das ist ein guter Film. Auf jeden Fall reingehen, ja, wenn ihr fein seid.
Was ist jetzt eigentlich mal kurz so organisatorisch gesehen?
Wie machen wir das jetzt bis zum Ende des Jahres noch mit Folgen?
Hauen wir noch eine Best-Off-Folge raus?
Die Best-Off-Folge ist geplant.
Ich gehe einfach stark davon aus, dass weder du noch ich Bock dazu haben, die zu schneiden.
Das heißt, die wird nicht rauskommen. Das heißt, es geht dann erst ab Anfang Januar wieder weiter. Okay, also das ist die letzte Folge quasi. Bis dahin posten wir euch einfach ein paar coole Links zu Videos, die ihr euch anschauen könnt, die auch Spaß machen. Ich kann auch sagen, wo die letzte Packung Toblerone gelandet ist. Die ist gelandet bei unseren Arschloch-Nachbarn. Im Schicksalsberg. Unseren Franzosen, unter uns sind ja Franzosen eingezogen und haben wir die getroffen und halt total die Lehmänner so, oh bonjour, wir sprechen noch nicht so gut Deutsch, hallo, willkommen, ah schön, ja, tolle Wohnung, wir treffen uns alle, wir machen eine große Feier und laden die ganze Wohnung ein und ja toll. Und wir dachten uns, geil, mal ein bisschen Nachbarschaftsfreundschaft, cool, Franzosen, total geil, die kommen aus Paris, haben bestimmt total viel erzählt.
Eine Woche nach Einzug flattert bei uns die erste Beschwerde ins Haus, Beschwerde wegen Ruhestörungen, sie haben sich direkt beim Vermieter beschwert, weil wir mal irgendwie Leute da hatten und ein bisschen Party, ja, du kennst mich, Party, Party gemacht haben.
Eine klassische Florentin-Will-Swinger-Party, wo irgendwann nackte Leute an der Tür gekratzt haben von den Franzosen und überall im Treppenhaus. Die YouTube-Videos waren vielleicht ein bisschen zu laut. Und einfach da und halt schon mega einfach direkt komplett in Hauswegen schief, einfach mega schlechte Stimmung. Mein Mitbegruder hat sich ein paar Mal auf dem Treppenhaus getroffen, einfach komplett eisig nicht gegrüsst, mega schlecht. Und jetzt ist genau bei denen meine scheiss Top-La-Rode-Packung angekommen, so von wegen, ah holen sie sie bei ihren Nachbarn ab. Aber die müssen es ja auch angenommen haben, aktiv, ne? Ja, aber das Problem ist, auf dem Zettel, den ich bekommen habe, steht es so extrem undeutlich drauf, dass ich erstens nicht weiß, ob ich ein Paket für Nachbarn bekommen habe oder ein Nachbarnpaket für mich bekommen habe, das erschließt sich einfach nicht. Ich kann keinen einzigen Namen auf diesem Ding lesen und das komische, ich kann es nicht anziffern, aber da steht für mich einfach, wo dieses Paket angekommen ist, Name steht einfach Andrew Laides, Andrew Laides, was einfach mal der Name ist, der Figur von Leonardo DiCaprio und Shutter Island, ja, was einfach ein bisschen strange ist. Ach, ist das sein echter Name, oder wird er sich irgendwann ausdenken, diese Anagram-Nummer? Ja, wir wollen nicht spoilern. Ach komm schon, ey, ich finde, man muss unseren Hörern so ein bisschen was erwarten, und Shutter Island gehört definitiv dazu. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, ob es jetzt sein Ausgedachter oder sein echter Name ist, aber es ist halt schon ein bisschen komisch, Andrew Laidis, und ich weiß auch nicht, wer wer das sein soll, weil wir haben keinen Laides in unserem Haus, also ich weiss es nicht. Und vor allem, es ist ja Toplerone, ne, ich dachte mir so, kann man das so als Semi-Weihnachtsgeschenk dann verbuchen, dass sie einfach irgendwann die aufmachen und dann Spaß haben mit der Toplerone, oder ich einfach so meinem Vorbeigehen so, ja, macht's einfach auf, ich will's gar nicht wieder haben, macht's einfach auf, frohe Weihnachten, weil ich einfach keine Lust habe, bei denen das abzuholen, weil das einfach, vor allem jetzt ist das schon ganze drei Wochen her und ich kann es nicht nach drei Wochen da anklopfen, so, bonjour, kann es sein, dass ihr aujourd'hui eine Pakete bekommen habt für mich oder weiss ich nicht. Ja, vielleicht lebst du die. Das finde ich nicht schlecht, wenn du genau so einfach wahnsinnig fremdenfeindlich mit ihnen sprechen würdest.
Aber mir geht's gerade, ich habe ironischerweise eine sehr ähnliche Geschichte gerade erlebt.
Na! wenn du genau so einfach wahnsinnig fremdenfeindlich mit denen sprechen würdest. Aber mir geht's gerade, ich hab ironischerweise eine sehr ähnliche Geschichte gerade erlebt. Also, nebenan ist nämlich die Pathologie, ich wohne direkt neben der Pathologie. Und ich weiß nicht warum, aber die arbeiten, die ganze fucking Nacht arbeiten die einfach. Und unter anderem wollte ich ja, dass du hier einziehst, in der Wohnung, damit du dieses Schlafzimmer, in dem ich gerade schlafe, übernimmst, weil ich einfach nicht mehr pennen kann hier, weil jede Nacht haben die einfach fucking Arbeiten zu erledigen. Warum machen die das nicht tagsüber? Die kratzen da immer von innen an der Tür oder was? Auch Sonntagnacht sind so ein Scheiss und dann klopfe ich dann fast jede Nacht einfach sehr doll gegen die Wand, weil ich mir denke, dann hören die, dass ich da bin und dann sind die auch meistens immer leiser. und das ist aber so ein bisschen so ein zweigeteilter Spiel, was ich mit denen da gerade treibe, weil ich den, wenn ich die auf dem Gang halt sehe, einfach immer so, wann ich Freudenstahlen begrüsse, weil ich einfach dafür viel zu eitel bin, dass ich dann irgendwie anfange, da irgendwie eine Diskussion mit denen zu führen.
Und jetzt wurde ein Paket bei mir abgegeben von denen, weil es eine Pathologie ist, ein bisschen gruselig ist, ich weiß nicht genau, was da drin ist, ob ich das so schnell abgeben muss, ob ich den Kühlschrank legen muss. Das ist eine geile Story, dann kriegst du ein falsches Paket zurück und da ist dann irgendwie so ein Kopf drin von deiner verflossenen Liebe. Und dann kommst du drauf, dass sie ermordet wurde oder irgendwie sowas. Denkt euch was aus. Aber tatsächlich dachte ich mir, vielleicht wäre das eine Möglichkeit für einen geilen Badass-Moment der Woche, ich plane ja meine Badass-Momente der Woche mittlerweile, dass ich vielleicht, wenn ich den Franzosen da begegne, was sie weniger Badass macht, was der Sinn der Sache ist, dass wenn ich ihnen dann begegne, so von wegen, ah, ich sehe, ihr habt euch ja schon ganz gut hier eingefunden, Denunzierertum hat in Deutschland eine lange Tradition, willkommen, Umhang, weil sie uns ja beim Vermieter schmeißt eine Pyrotechnik auf den Boden und im Dampf verschwindet er und der Feueralarm geht los. Umhang weht auf und ich gleite das Treppenhaus hinunter. Ja. Aber wir haben ja dieses ewige Problem mit unserer scheiß Haustür. Dass immer im Miethaus gibt es zwei Parteien. Die, die wollen, dass diese Tür abgesperrt wird. Also nicht nur geschlossen, sondern abgesperrt, und die Partei, die nicht will, dass sie abgesperrt ist. Weil wenn dann zum Beispiel ein Pizzabote kommt, dann kann man ja so den reinbuzzern und dann kann er die Tür aufmachen und die die Pizza bringen. Aber meistens ist sie abgeschlossen, weil irgendwie vor drei Jahren mal da eingebrochen wurde. Weil jemand ermordet wurde. Weil irgendjemand irgendwie mehrfach vergewaltigt und ermordet wurde und eine Woche lang im Keller festgehalten wurde. So ein Quatsch. So, und deswegen soll die abgesperrt werden und deswegen gibt es halt einfach immer diese wunderschönen Momente, dass man sich dann im Treppenhaus oh, sie haben jetzt gerade gar nicht abgesperrt. Ne, wir sperren generell nicht ab. Ja, ich dachte nur, weil es gab ja hier vor viereinhalb Jahren mal Einbrüche. Ja, wir dachten uns aber, wenn Feuer ausbricht und wir alle fliehen müssen, dann kann die Tür ja nicht abgesperrt sein. Also so Katastrophe versus Katastrophe. Geil, einfach, dass man sich so übertrumpft, dass man so Trumpf spielt, irgendwie um die krassesten Katastrophen-Stories, die ich gerade ausdenken kann. Und sich im Haus aber auch so zwei Parteien bilden, die sich irgendwann mal in so einem Kriegsschlachtfeld einfach gegenüberstehen und aufeinander reinlaufen. Wovor haben wir Angst? Feuer! Wovor haben wir keine Angst? Vergewaltigung! Yay! Oh, jetzt ist es recht. Und dann so eine Braveheart-Rede, du führst dann irgendwie vor den Leuten. Ah, wie großartig. Feuer ist ja schlimm, sehr feindes Menschen. Und das ist doch schön, weil das ist immer so ein Showdown. Und dann sagt er, ja, ich habe Angst vor Vergewaltigung, ja, ich habe Angst vor Feuer. Okay. Ja, muss man da wohl abwägen. Schöne Weihnachten, kommen Sie gut rein, neun soll ja, tschüss. Das einzige, worüber wir mit unseren Nachbarn reden, ist nur die Vorstellung, bei lebendigem Leib zu verbrennen, weil man das Haus nicht verlassen kann. Oder am lebendigen Leib vergewaltigt zu werden. Das sind so unsere Gesprächsthemen. Ich bin sogar noch einen Schritt weiter, gehe ich sogar noch. Ich bin dafür, dass man Pizzaboten und Postboten einen Schlüssel geben sollte, damit sie reinkommen, ohne reingebuzzert zu werden. Also ich bin noch einen Schritt weiter als Buzzerer, weil es mir auf die Nerven geht, dass irgendwer um sieben Uhr morgens alle aus dem Schlaf klingelt. Überall hört man diese Klingel im Haus und dann machen alle gleichzeitig auf, alle rennen gleichzeitig zur Tür und sind wach und buzzern gleichzeitig gleichzeitig und dann kommt er reingelaufen und ruft, hallo, Post, danke und geht wieder, weil er einfach, weil die Briefkästen sich innen befinden. Ich hätte mir da auch schon so eine ganze Rede vorbereitet, wenn die Franzosen dann meinen, so, ja, es wäre schon ein bisschen, wenn sie die Tür abschliessen und ich so, jetzt ist nicht die Zeit gekommen für Angst. Es ist die Zeit der Tritoblerone. Es ist die Zeit Angst vor Feuer. Natürlich gibt es Gefahren da draußen, aber sollen wir uns deswegen einsperren und uns verstecken? Nein, wir lassen uns nicht einschüchtern. Wenn wir Angst haben, haben die da draußen gewonnen. Je suis Charlie! Eine große Brandrede einfach dafür, dass wir weder Angst vor Terroristen noch vor Jugendbanden, weil so ein bisschen der Kampfbegriff der Seite ist, so Jugendbanden, was zur Hölle das auch immer sein soll.
Jugendbanden.
Ich habe gerade noch ein bisschen, ich glaube, ich leg mich gleich wieder hin, ich bin echt noch ein bisschen müde und habe noch ein bisschen so eine kratzige Stimme.
Ich bin auch müde.
Erst wenn ein Podcast all diese Anforderungen erfüllt, dann ist er der, der Glück ist, was die Seele durcheinander rüttelt. Das Podcast-Ufels. Kennst du das, wenn du so müde bist, dass du eigentlich schlafen wolltest, aber so viel Kaffee getrunken hast, dass du zwar müde bist, aber dein Geist so seltsam wach ist und du andauernd so Dinge siehst und dich ganz viel ausdenkst und plötzlich deine Gedanken einfach hin und her springen und man so in so einer Schwebebe sich befindet? Nee. Ich auch nicht. Was ich vorhin natürlich nochmal ansprechen wollte, wo Stefan Taigo mich rüde unterbrochen hat, ist natürlich unser Geniales. Also Weihnachten ist ja immer die Zeit der Geschenke. Und da haben wir uns natürlich vom Podcast UVV gedacht, Mensch, was können wir unserer Community schenken? Und da ist uns natürlich eine tolle Idee gekommen, und zwar gibt es jetzt, ihr habt es vielleicht schon bemerkt, unser Geschenk für euch, euer Geschenk für uns, Pornhub, nein, die Pufopedia, Pedia, Pedia, Pedia, Pedia, die allumschliessende, umfassende Online-Enzyklopädie zum Erfolgspodcast, das Podcast-UFO. Und ich wollte noch mal sagen, vielen, vielen Dank an die tollen, tollen Artikel, die schon da drin stehen. Es ist ein großer Spaß, aber eines verstehe ich nicht, wenn man auf zufällige Artikel klickt, kommt andauernd Donny O'Sullivan. Und ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass er da irgendwie was gedreht hat, an dem Lygarhythmus gedreht. Wir haben da einen Deal abgeschlossen, ja. Nee, tatsächlich so, es ist eine komplette Online-Wikipedia, die sich nur mit dem Podcast-Ufo befasst, pufopedia.de, und ihr könnt alle eure eigenen Artikel schreiben, was natürlich ein gewisses Risiko ist. Und wo ich mir dachte, oh scheiße, ich weiß nicht, welche Leute wir da alle anziehen und ob dann irgendjemand alles löscht. Es gibt tatsächlich auch ein paar, die das Format nicht hundertprozentig verstanden haben, aber zum absoluten überwiegenden grossen Teil haben da richtig coole Leute, richtig coole Artikel geschrieben. Und es macht richtig Spaß, das mal mit durchzulesen. Und jeder kann seine eigenen Artikel schreiben. Wir brauchen noch Artikel für jede einzelne Folge, wo dann irgendwie so Informationen, kurz zusammengefasst, worum es geht, vielleicht so die besten Zitate oder sowas. Transkripte im krassesten Fall. Und es ist richtig cool, weil es ist ein Community-Projekt von der Community, für die Community, jeder kann sich beteiligen.
Richtig cool und ganz toll, da könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen, wenn ihr zu Weihnachten unterm Weihnachtsbaum euch langweilt und auf eurem neuen Android S6 irgendwie ein bisschen cool was zu essen wollt. Wenn ihr ein langweiliges Leben führt, so langweilig ist, aber die Weihnachtszeit, nicht wisst, was ihr machen soll und dann auf Puffo Peter geht, habt ihr die Kontrolle über euer Leben verloren, aber naja. Lest euch mal durch und ich sag mal so, am besten haben mir die geheimen Artikel gefallen, die man nicht so leicht findet. Nun gut, viel Spaß. Aber wie genau, also man kann doch nicht genau Seiten anklicken, also man kann nicht Artikel anklicken, sondern man muss halt immer die suchen, also du musst antizipieren, worüber es Artikel geben könnte. Das ist ein bisschen, das macht es ein bisschen schwierig. Wie du meinst, es gibt keine Übersicht von allen Artikeln, die es gibt. Ja, genau, irgendwie so eine Inhalts... Das kann man vielleicht machen. Das gibt es aber bei Wikipedia auch nicht, glaube ich. Nee, genau, aber da weisst du halt, dass es von allem was gibt. Naja. Ey Mann, ich habe mich da echt fucking reingearbeitet in die ganze Scheiße, das war gar nicht so einfach, den Scheiß zu installieren. Ich bin froh, dass es überhaupt geklappt hat. Nee, jetzt müsste halt jemand mal so eine kleine Übersicht machen, so eine Seite, wer da Bock hat. Aber da gibt es schon coole Leute, die das machen. Und es wäre natürlich geil, wenn wir es von der Sprache und vom Stil her so ein bisschen in einem Wikipedia-Stil haben können. Ich glaube, dann ist es am lustigsten und dann funktioniert es am besten, wenn man da nicht jetzt irgendwie so grosse, geschwollene Texte schreibt, sondern einfach in einem klaren, faktischen Stil bleibt. Finde ich, glaube ich, ganz cool, was natürlich schon wahnsinnig viele Leute richtig gut gemacht haben. Vielen Dank dafür, klickt euch mal durch, puffopedia.de Ah! Ansonsten wünscht das ganze Ufo, Podcast-Ufo-Team die Redakteure, Cordula, die Autoren, die Autorengruppe, der Autorenpool, die Produzenten, die Kater, wir alle wünschen ein tolles, angenehmes Jahr 2016. Schenkt euch auch mal selbst etwas. Schenkt euch Freude, macht euch Freude auch. Was brauche ich eigentlich? Was sind meine Wünsche? Geht mal in euch, kommt mal ein bisschen zur Ruhe, relax mal ein bisschen, max relax, kommt mal ein bisschen zur Ruhe und natürlich startet ganz fantastisch ins neue Jahr. Eine schöne Weihnachtszeit könnte das beste Jahr aller Zeiten werden, wir wissen es noch nicht, macht das beste draus. Florentin und ich und das ganze Perfekt. Es war ein geiles Jahr, oder? Es war ein cooles Jahr. Es war ein geiles Jahr, ey! Es war geil, was wir alles gemacht haben, man, wir waren in Basel, wir waren in Hamburg, wir waren in Aachen bei Cordula, wir haben viele Fans getroffen,
im Boeing, wir haben unseren ersten Stand-up gemacht, wir haben da Fans getroffen, wir haben unseren Merchandise-Store gestartet, viele Leute haben Bilder gepostet, wir haben coole Fans, wir haben eine geile Community, Podcast UFO ist abgehoben in diesem Jahr. Ja, und nächstes Jahr wird es noch mehr abheben, wir machen Live-Events, wöchentliche Live-Events. Ja, mal gucken.
Gut, vielleicht schaffen wir ein Live-Event.
Ich war ja beim Live-Event von Gäste-Liste Geisterbahn,
was richtig, richtig geil war.
Vielleicht machen wir 2016 ein Live-Event, wo dann mal alle zusammenkommen können und dann könnt ihr euch auch mal aneinander reiben, wenn ihr das wollt.
Und das wäre natürlich cool, mal gucken, ob wir das hinkriegen,
ob wir das mit unserem Narzissmus vereinbaren können,
der sich mit Scham und Schüchternheit paart.
Mal gucken, ob wir das schaffen.
Ansonsten, ey, es war ein geiles Jahr, das nächste Jahr wird auch geil.
Hört mal die alten Folgen, die sind auch nicht schlecht.
Bis dann, macht's gut, wir heben ab, wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr.
Macht's gut, tschaui, baui, tschaui.